it was cool to be in a country of like
real athletes you know what I mean like
the like the cricket Champions oh were
there dude that was one of my the best
parts about Australia I hated I thought
of you guys and I hated you guys I it
made me so happy I to know that you were
in India just watching your team get
[__] Molly wed they got [__] dude
they got not [__] like they got
screwed by the refs they played terribly
they lost couple unlucky breaks it was
the worst it was one of the worst
experience life lose that your own sport
make it up English sport really I they
running that [__] sor right dude kid Cy
name is cuz he cuts himself you know
what I mean like sometimes think you
know things and you don't know things
Australians are the best they are the
best they're like the dynasty Team
Champions nobody's woned six time and
it's pretty unbelievable yeah they are
they are the Lakers they're the Celtics
they're that that's part of I think why
we've folded and India is known as like
the choke team and we did choke also by
the way shouts to prize picks they we
were I was doing the World Cup of
cricket prize picks while I was there
and for this week's NFL games I'm going
more all the way the sing locks okay
which may or may not be locks use your
best judgment quite frankly I got
Brandon Cooks getting more than 40 and a
half uh receiving yards for Dallas
Jaylen Herz getting more than 36 and a
half rushing yards 100% it's against San
Francisco but I got faith in the Philly
Run game sadly I hate to admit it also
DeAndre Swift more than 56 and a half
rushing yards those are my prize picks
go to prize picks.com use a promo code
Schultz they'll match your initial entry
of $100 up to that $100 so you put 100
they're going to match up to 100 exactly
that's beautiful you said that better
than me now listen we in this together
we're Team okay we are teams go to priz
pick.com get that 100% deposit match up
to $100 with the pro promo code Schultz
s CZ you got this okay now let's get
back to the show I'm so positive I'm
going to have the greatest Sports
Experience in my life I don't sleep I I
overpay by 10x for these tickets yeah
can you can you break down the whole
thing cuz I remember dming you I'm like
you're going to the thing and you're
like we're going to try I go try well sh
you're in [__] India sh was saying he
could get free tickets and he did but it
was taking a long time so I just bought
calm down
bro real [__] angry like Raise Your
Voice with me like you're making me feel
a little bit uncomfortable take that
take that take hey come on dude take
that come on dude come on
dude more fun gets free tickets yeah
yeah shout out to sh sh's Dad we hung
out he's the sweetest guy well I I paid
for mine anyway and then why does he
have free tickets I think sh's Dad is a
mob boss or some [__]
dude like I mean the guy got us into
like this VIP box oh wow for a little
bit was too tall to be like
malnutrition is like what 6'2 6'4
something he's like a tall in yeah he's
he's and his dad just like you could
tell he just run
[__] so first was he doing that Indian
[__] that you say where you got to like
yell at people like they servants I
didn't see him interact with a ton of
people which also made me think he was
even richer that I didn't have to see
even come all that was we had a car the
whole day like I'm ordering Ubers when
I'm in India or whatever we just had
look like a guy in sandals walks up with
a
basket he pulls up in a moped actually
wait are there moped Ubers out there no
but that's fire yeah that would be kind
of dope well we would I I saw three or
four to a moped at one point it was
crazy how many people were on One
Scooter they should have that I think
they call that a freak
off uh but yeah so Chip's dad get so I
give away my tickets and then we go into
the arena it's 130,000 people there's no
big four Sports there's one sport we
care about yeah okay sorry sorry sorry
break it down a little bit okay 130,000
so the size of the arena is it uh Dallas
it's bigger than every stadium in the
world it's the biggest stadium in the
world and this is in where again in
gadat in Amad Amad okay so sizewise it's
not only the length of a football field
it's a complete circle it's a complete
circle okay 130,000 people and what's
the town around it look like is it shops
businesses or is it like way out it's a
metropolitan City and it's built up a
lot the prime minister is from there so
I think also they made it a point to
build that City's infrastructure up a
little more even in the past years look
at this [__] thing it's insane and
it's all these people rooting for one
team mhm and it's the World Cup of the
Australians go there or no there was I
didn't see a single one I don't think
but they showed a few on the screen yeah
I saw you like 15 you just see like a
couple of yellow jerseys or whatever
gotcha how hard is it to follow the game
I at this I'm a casual but it's an easy
sport to follow even as a casual there's
little things I don't know like what
like off leg means or whatever the [__]
I don't know what that means but you can
keep up with the basics of who's winning
and who's not but meaning like for
example soccer at a distance is still
very enjoyable yes like even when you
play the video game of soccer you're
kind of like far yeah whereas uh like
football football far away sucks kind of
sucks yeah this is a round stadium and
it's I sh was saying it's built in a
certain way where it seats it doesn't
necessarily matter how high you are
because you still get a different
vantage point on what's going on and
you're fine okay so there's not really
bad seats got it we had the face value
of our tickets were high but then I
looked at the seats that I would have
gotten originally and those that I gave
away those were good too I was looking
at that area I was like oh you're close
that seems great so every seat is good
and I cannot explain the emotional
Stakes that if India won it would have
been the greatest one of the greatest
experiences of my life like it have been
insane imagine going to Argentina the
World Cup is in Argentina Argentina's in
the final and the stadium is the biggest
stadium in the world packed with
argentinians just dying for their team
to win not root for India in that oh
yeah I mean dude when we India started
off on the when they were balling
bowling they were uh like they were
doing well at first and I was like yo we
might [__] win this now and I was
getting so hyped does everybody there
think that they have a chance to win it
entering the tournament no not every
team have some teams no no no no no no
meaning this game are Indians going yo
we think we're winning okay got it it's
we are the favorites Australia's the
dynasty team so you're a little
concerned about that and India has a
reputation for choking
so I heard uncles in India being like
they're going to choke don't worry about
don't get caught up in this they're
going to choke but for the most part
they they beat everybody it's like we're
Bills fans this is the only sport we
care about but it's not a City of
Buffalo with not that many people it's a
country of a billion people 1.4 billion
people the point4 is bigger than America
which is crazy but yeah that's we're all
rooting for this thing and it just
doesn't happened and it was the saddest
[__] walk out ever that that was wild
the point four biger America wild right
it's now the biggest country in the
world right in terms of population yeah
past China it's the biggest country and
it's good cuz it's a lot of young people
so they think that's going to propel
India economically whereas before I
don't think we saw that so they not just
[__] mud then no they not we coming
we we're coming real can I be honest
with you can I be honest with you that's
a lot of [__] Indi Indians might give
Mexicans a run for their money bro in
terms of people culture and ability
to
just just just believeing just
Bing I had to hit up my boy Al I done
Miss Hime I done miss him I I done
missed them I had to hit my boy up a
little bit I feel like you're talking
about the men to be
honest that's more about the women's
abilities than the men's ability that's
that might be the case did you guys
notice akos never looked happy in a
single picture while he was out
there until he was at the
game the game I was least happy cuz we
were losing oh cuz it was stressful yeah
how he looked miserable the entire time
out there did y'all get sick at all did
you get sick no I didn't get sick I had
the crazy insomnia worst insomnia maybe
I've ever had the past three weeks
really yeah including when I went to
Dallas but so maybe that's why I think
I'm just a super finicky sleeper like
the the beds in India are not
comfortable if you're going to a fivar
hotel it's all amazing why don't you
stay with SH cuz sh didn't he was in a
different city than me oh and he was he
didn't get there till like the day
before the match I had that was my last
day in India was the day of the match I
extended my trip by one day to fly to
the match see the match whole thing
didn't sleep yeah and did you go visit
your broke ass family or how was that
with all due respect no I visited my my
wife's family actually and they're
they're doing fine but it's not like
five star hotel nice I can't believe
y'all didn't get bring presents buto
that's that's that's crazy bro you got
to bring something nice from
America like what cash did you
traditionally or [__] Scot like when
our parents used to go they used to take
a suitcase full of gifts but the family
that I would have that would need the
gifts is on my mom's side and I couldn't
even see them again because of the air
quality Deli it was so bad yeah what
what gifts did you bring to whenever you
go to developing country you bring gifts
that's a thing I didn't know in India it
was a thing I don't see it as much now
you might bring like some candy or some
[__] BR soda bring and they like that
but what did they bring when your
parents went what would they bring oh
dude sometimes these kids would ask for
like sometimes people still ask for like
an iPhone or some [__] and it's like
that's crazy but they used to ask for
just like some Electronics or whatever
you could bring up a vibrator I think VI
I think we're fine on the [__] with
1.4 billion people I don't think that's
why you need the vibrator get good point
they I don't think that we give enough
credit to Indian dick game you talk a
lot of [__] like your dick game ain't
nice but it might be not nice compared
compared to 1. yeah if y'all making the
most babies for the best best that's
[__]
got it let's just call it what it is
could let call it what it is yeah
Indians might have the best [__] game on
the planet you just might the numbers
don't lie it's also a testament to
arrange marriages that's true you get it
lined up and then babies on Deck bang
bang bang yeah it's kind of fire shout
out India mhm how many Africans let me
see that's not a country I don't care
like we we taking all of that it don't
matter I'm repping all that that's not a
country repping it I'm repping
it shut up 1.2 billion God your whole
continent cucks godamn C Dude tell D go
to India time of his
life take your next take your next C the
the slave trade hurt us it hurt us you
talking about the Bad Boy Records or
what are you saying yo come on what I
say you're being political again Rick
show is going to get blown
up he doesn't even have a guard can't
even hide the bomb got to put it on the
seat you chill outo that's why we ride
on top of the trains we're doing bomb
inspections we got to make you got to
check it out got to make sure did you
see anybody doing that or is that
complete I didn't see Bangalore where we
went is like the most Western Country in
India so it's it's not America you still
are in India on a scooter they doing
that on scooters doing our Trad like
godam too many people to be [__]
around out Mexican Mexicans no don't say
that son Mexicans will put like six in a
car I bet you they'll probably do like
12 what here I bet you they can get 12
of them [__] in there but they
can't fix a car no no can fix a car no
you can't they don't either fix it right
there n y'all do ride the most look at
that [__] that's this looks like it's
made to seed 4 though it's like those
double seed bicycles but we still put
two on each seat look that one crazy go
go over go over go to the Mexicans right
there go this way one more first one
more over one there it is right there
this one that's the same picture the
same picture we were just looking at you
[__] idiot oh
but damn bro stop getting Indian [__]
wrong he hasn't slept in 6 weeks come on
give him a break five on a scooter right
so that's impressive no I've never seen
a Mexican do that they got Step It Up in
sandal mind four five six that's six
that's crazy oh yeah there's a six a
sneak baby with a sombrero that's a
Mexican child they stole that's crazy
this is insane how they Ste it's insane
anyway shout out to
India how was the
rest it I know I don't know [__] about
India I [__] consent it I have a six
sense to how gay you're going to be and
I want to go there with you I want to
[__] be there with you tell me it's
home dude it's home it's just home
that's it I don't know how to put it any
other way my heart is home when I'm
there that's all I know how to say
that's as gay as I'm going to be but i'
love
it I would love I I can't wait to go
dude people would ask me about you
they'd be like when are you bring an
Andrew he found a way to bring me into
this his [__] emotional stimulus he
needs attention I need stimulus I hate
constant stimulus my wife is reading a
book what will I do I know this man God
that was good that was good smart
[__] Indi bro they might they're
coming for I don't know if Mexican could
do that I don't know if Mexicans got
that holy [__] are you saying that
they're going to top I don't I don't
want to even say it dude they might dude
but they might be the goats bro you have
to warn the Mexicans hey Step It Up get
to it India is coming for you dud 1.4
great was there a moment there that that
truly made you feel home and I'm not
trying to set you up for anything gay no
I think a lot of it also I I wonder cuz
I wonder I want to when you guys go I
want to go family is like the main thing
for me family that I don't ever see that
I don't ever get to connect with my
wife's family so sweet so like that's
the main thing for me when I'm there I'm
like oh this is home this is what I've
been missing a good political answer
right there you heard that but a
politician this guy's a [__]
politician you are a little politician
though Indians comment when you go home
it's it's like the family dude and you
don't realize so I pivot he didn't even
acknowledge that [__] just like I'm keep
going that's true cuz he was supposed to
be a politician he stayed in India and
it's still in him a little bit and now
it's coming out you went back to the
source so it's really coming out the way
that you just shouted out how amazing
your wife's family was was just Indians
comment he's got them in the chat going
crazy what are they saying Mark BS
and was good so what what was the moment
that you're like [__] this feels great
I'm home walking through just a couple
times I was
kidding Jing I just remember walking
this is that we're walking through a
park it shouldn't even be it's just a
park it's a nice park but there's in
America everywhere what's in it it trees
plants leaves Indians but there's I'm
just walking through it I'm looking at
the streets of bangal on my left I'm
just in a park Indians
everywhere l i can get you back I get
bring it back okay you know how you guys
are walking through America you see
white people you're like oh that's just
people and then you see a black person
you're like hey a black person
okay in India you're the people I see
Indians I'm like yeah it's just people
I'm just people if I saw a white guy I
was like Hey a white guy that's weird
the feeling you guys have every day as a
majority so you felt normal for the
first time yeah you feel I'm home you
feel regular yeah I'm I'm not an Indian
guy I'm just a guy normal person I'm
just a guy all them love handles he's
like I'm in sh that's not true 57 is
what I saw being pretty average I was
like this did you feel tall out there no
I'm normal heye I'm normal 5 average
height not tall but I'm average height
wow Al you would be tall out there I'm
tall here [__] no not with the not I'm
saying without the lifts still tall